louis vor naja
da sie noch beko sachen falls ihr euch
noch ein bisschen
so herzlich willkommen heute für montag
11 uhr morgens um gewonnen
also machte sie machten
das wollte damit erreichen dass gold
bereit ich kenne sie meinen ist so geben
wie ich verstehe ja schon bekommen zu
eurem lieblings format drei cocktails
die ballern heute drei überraschungs
kopf 75 cocktails die ballern
sie sind die musik abräumer dieses
winters die vier jungs von tokio hotel
falls ihr tokio hotel nicht kennt aus
irgendeinem grund will sich mal wieder
vorstellen hallo ich bin georg eine
spielebox hallo ich bin größer wurden
ich versuche mich an den trommeln hallo
ich bin ich bin die sängerin weil ich
bin wer es noch über tom und die gern
klavier
und ich bin es allemal
sonst machen wir drei cocktails mit
einer zutat heute wird es so sein dass
ich fünf klassische cocktails genommen
habe die habe ich in ihre einzelteile
zerstückelt und in diese schüsselchen
verteilt jeder muss ein zettel aus jeder
schüssel ziehen und so kommt dann der
frankenstein kommt zustande weil ich bin
so aufgeregt werden bereut ihr vorhin
schon trinken ja ihr habt ihr die
möglichkeit doch 11 uhr morgens noch
direkt zwei trinken
frey klick oder berliner luft
guck mal rechts bekommt ein auge ist
schon rüber gewanderten
experte
wie eine professionelle macht er das als
ob ich schon mal schluss getrunken hätte
das ist für mich mehr getrunken auf
jeden fall ein geschenk nicht so richtig
über berlin ist geben wir uns noch mal
bei uns nicht
immer im regen hier mal vor jedem
konzert nach jedem konzert
und immer in die hose wir sehen
[Musik]
der anfang mit ziel ich würde fragen wir
gehen vielleicht alphabetisch oder der
reihe nach es schwierig wir waren alle
noch nicht so weit
[Musik]
liest schon mal fordern stelle ich dir
schon mal alles hin leben
sein ausgedruckte nötigen ruhe
glasgow schwester soße es spricht man
dass rohstoffe sind trotzdem hat ja wir
wussten nämlich nicht wie man das auf
gerichte hier sind ja 1 1 mainburgs
cluster so
[Musik]
brauner zucker
und liebeskrise matif das ist mein
lieblingscharakter das nicht mein ding
und zum schluss
die mary glas wodka hg zweiter ko system
blue curacao
so dass auch hier verbessert meine
mischung ananas sagt der würde richtig
dass man
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kann jetzt schon über das ziel ist das
ein betrug us bank mit
und durch so eine sache ergaunerte sich
ein punkt bootskorso
glas wodka die messen saft grenadinen
das topping ist schlagsahne
das wird auch nicht dass sie das eis
keine politik gegen
das ist das haus an die das glas rum
mann war gestern erst bis zur versenkung
was haben wir hier kostet also
[Musik]
ja es macht wach und
auch ganz bitter und sellerie sahne du
fängst an hinten hat ja geil mensch bist
du so gemein ohne mich wenn wir nächste
saison gegen paderborn spiel
jeweils hätte er das nicht gewusst von
flächen davon gibt es bei uns davon tag
jetzt ist es endlich raus so das motto
das andere das mitwissen
[Musik]
das gerät mehr was ich dazu noch sagen
soll zurück zu dir ein studio kathrin
auf die gesundheit zu sein und auch
vierkampf
und qualität
so einfach mit euch nun habe ich schon
gefragt wann ist es trocken kann ihr
macht das schon selber also macht wenn
ihr auch ab und zu den song mal ansehen
wollten
[Musik]
das
gut sehr gut
die tür ich so hart welche the darkness
kommen
bei diesen herr lasso dafür wir dachten
wir wären denn die dunkelheit begeben da
einfach mal was im kleinen team ist jung
sexy
[Musik]
ja und darum passt ja auch eigentlich
perfekt mit den kopf die zweite gute
heute trinkt man mal einen tagen aber
eigentlich trägt man erstens
wir haben hier nur ganz genau ausgelotet
kaum liegt die ganze zeit es ist schön
dass ja aber es ist doch das klingt
jetzt auf jeden fall wieder hommage an
die dunkelheit an die nacht
albträume ich auch diesmal trifft es
schlecht manchmal
an sich kommt schon dicht raum schon oft
schlecht dran auch von trennungen und so
von der kammer nicht haben auch zu
alpträumen die sind so realistisch dass
wir angst haben einzuschlafen oder was
auch vorkommt ist das schlecht träumen
und er denkt dass das ist auf jeden fall
passiert ist einfach toll findest dann
den menschen sauer
ich habe so realistisch zu träumen das
ist das ist meine ich brauche um zu
realisieren dass
das kenne ich sie mussten sich auch
schon einiges anhören musste sich auch
schon einige male entschuldigen einfach
mal zu mir sind die leute halt einfach
im wahren leben auch so böse das ist vom
albtraum nicht so viel
wie aber ich habe phasen wo ich angst
habe einzuschlafen also so krass dann
habe ich wirklich angst oder dann falle
ich auch immer wieder in meinen traum
rein und trainieren weiter man muss ja
wirklich aufstehen rumlaufen kunst
einmal dürfte damit ich nicht wieder
zurück in diesem traum falle ich habe
richtig probleme aber deswegen dachten
wir wir machen nomad an die träume
vielleicht wird sie jetzt besser oder
dorfen ihr aber der ist auch das ist
schön und china finanziert
genau heißt mit dem song ein bisschen
weniger alkohol vielleicht hilft das ja
wegen alkohol
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
wird jedoch wieder verliert
[Musik]
wir machen einfach freistaat also weil
ich da jetzt hier die andere einfach
ganz wild denkt
doch dann sah man übrigens also bezahlen
ich meine wir sind ja auch viele leute
[Musik]
schon die idee wie es bei dir lustige
eigentlich ne diana klar auf jeden fall
was hier trinke ich die flasche wert ist
das eigentlich
aber knallt das auch das ist er hat nie
das schön doch das hat ein
gutachten aber trainer die nicht
okay
brauchen wir das gleiche da
steht bei mir hier mal ran woche die
kopfkissen dazu hab ne bei mir wird sind
so maliger cocktail
ich liebe das ja ich liebe diese
eskalation
bitte nicht so meine hände vor dem
körper gerade
mal mit ihr zu drehen ok ja echt bitter
hat schon vorher der konzern die ganze
nacht nicht schlafen
das ist aber für mehrere leute darum
machen wir
da muss was dran warum geht ihr wieder
auf tour waren ist so heuer wir gehen
ehrlich wieder wir waren ja als corona
los gegen waren wir ja
unglücklicherweise gerade auf tour wir
hatten uns vorbereitet genau wenn man in
südamerika seit ewigkeiten mal die tour
gestartet in der mexiko gespielt wir
waren gerade in ekuador dieser wir
sollten ganz ganz viele termine spielen
wir waren seit jahren endlich mal wieder
da haben uns super lang vorbereitet und
dann muss man leider alle nach hause
fliegen mussten alle termine absagen
dürfen wir endlich wieder aufzugehen wir
gehen im april und mai nächsten jahr
genau wir fangen in mailand an und dann
nochmal london und stiegen ab 567 stoßen
in deutschland macht ja auch berlin aber
auch ganz prima in frankreich italien
russland wir haben jetzt gerade zur
release-party vom freitag haben war zum
ersten mal wieder gespielt habe seit
anderthalb jahren zusammen war zuerst
mal wieder somit publikum mit leuten
weiter vorangetrieben sodass wir haben
die golden gekommen heißt es aus der
stichwahl war in deutschland österreich
und der schweiz genau du hast du viele
andere musiker
eigentlich also ja mit 14 angefangen und
seitdem beibehalten eigentlich eine
frage macht man sich schon mit den check
mit dem trecker machen will meinte klopp
glaubt ihm bisschen genau mit einer
hohlen hand ja nicht der
experten im podcast überraschen mich auf
48 abgeholt gefühl dass ihr euch da
immer die cocktails gemischt hat oder
soja oder
mittlerweile heute zu diesen berufen
wird ganz trinken das ist ja so in der
presse die geräte fraktion gesunde
vitamine kommentare hinter mir ein ich
habe zu meinen dass in meinem kopf
werden also
nur in maßen und und auch er da stehen
wo
chf und die konfirmation oder
jugendweihe was mache ich mir das an die
ich mache die umlage wird ein schöner
kampf
an
also habe ich war heiß war drin es
klingt nicht nach äpfeln
zu ist auch wirklich
dass sie gut aussah
kurz das ist meine größte konkurrentin
der nation lecker
schmeckt die meiner ist richtig
und man kümmert schon mal ganz positiv
immer mehr als
schlusspunkt also auf jeden fall schon
mal einen punkt und der sieht ja wohl
yummy yummy yummy yummy die mittel
schnell trinken mb ist haben wirklich
ein bisschen zu engagieren da ist meine
rolle
wie kräftig sieht der leser auf bitte
ihr könnt euch auch schon den namen dazu
ausdenken hab das ist alles macht
meiner ist vom vom bild kinder
spitznamen inspirierte heißt la die
blinder
zugedreht
du hast
podcast wir haben diesen tollen dreht
hier organisiert und dann dachte ich so
recht doch mal rein in den podcast
der ersten folge war ich gucke dann hab
ich noch an meiner managerin gesagt hat
er auch noch mal rein ist vielleicht
haben wir noch ein paar themen über die
wir reden können und die hat auch gesagt
jetzt alles durch
also das ist ein sehr sehr guter podcast
sage ich heute uns sehr dass wir haben
auch vor spaß daran ich dachte ja jetzt
beim kunden warum ich auf wirtschaft
besser als bei trockener das machen was
sagt mir wenn es leute also meiner heißt
hoch die hände wochenende
meiner heißt bergfest dann heißt meiner
die tricks aber auch guck mal
nein gesagt das material sollte ich
vergessen habe
[Musik]
ich würde sagen ob das alles ob das
kommt meiner dann lange lange nichts und
dann die muttermilch wie zuerst einmal
alles so schön aussehen dann können wir
ja
whistler
thierry mariani
blätter seien
es war der 4
hier kam sie nach
müller
[Musik]
exklusives weg
cham
[Musik]
wir sind fertig dass unsere cocktails
ich würde alle wirklich sehr sehr schön
gelungen besonders der von bild ja die
kirche ist wichtig sagt und richtig und
christa darf jetzt als erstes vorstellen
ja ist eine der frühesten wir noch
pacman denn aber ich glaube ich wäre bei
muttermilch wir haben mir einen anleihe
eur freu mich drauf guten amerikanischen
whisky mit einem hauch von weißer zucker
mit schlagsahne und
dass ich dann immer respekt ich glaube
ich weiß jetzt schon dass er schmeckt
ich finde sehr spannend weil deine deko
finde ich kann doch nicht so weit kommen
dass ihm nichts als motto aus
ich sage nur was ist also ich finde es
ist kein richtig runter fahren dabei wir
werden nicht trocken da hat dann sagt
das ja auch ein top pick
ja du hast ja topic idee gut
und bei mir ist es also mein kopf heißt
erstmal bloody blinder komplett kinder
nahmen auch schon früher angefangen zu
bechern die die deko ist natürlich ich
glaube selbst erklärend man das ein
bisschen gesünder da ist rum drin da ist
tomatensaft drin also alles was man was
man braucht ein gesundes leben ein
bisschen zitronensaft und sellerie und
diese diesem etwas unpassendes pannier
ist einfach wer auch immer ein bisschen
panne aussah und
die frisur im grease ist auch seine
frisur weil das ist ein bisschen panne
und darum ist es einfach
ist schon wieder so
machen mir eine nummer zu gut das ist zu
viel geschichte dahinter zu sehen
ja das würde ich nicht gewohnt also
mainz ist der
kaffee kaffee hier kommst dicaprio kam
so gabriel hier kommen diese capri mit
orangensaft wodka grenadinen und
schlagsahne damit dass vor diesem
kaffeegeschmack wie er ist mein traum
exemplar was natürlich auch eine
wunderschöne farbe hat ich dachte
übrigens schon ein kleines ton aber es
schmeckt der job ist es die hände
wochenende und in meinem ist drin wodka
blue curacao kokosnuss nicht die kolosse
natürlich unsere brause und andere das
sagt genau also guten appetit der
schmeckt einfach noch mal hat sich auf
dem frankenstein hat kein bordell cdu zu
sagen
ich hab den wunderschönen cocktail
bergfest und der sieht sehr stark nach
dem vorbild von wild lieblings cocktail
der espressomaschine niemanden genau
aber diesmal in der ausführung mit
tequila espresso busch ist
minze in der hohlen hand geschlagen na
ja wunderbar auch live geschickt und
dann auch noch verziert natürlich mit
der minze und rohrzucker zum verlängern
wunderbar wunderbar wir bei uns immer
sagen man nicht darum sei
die partie wird gegessen wir machen wir
denn ohne rumsauer 1 punkten sogar schon
[Applaus]
da wir haben jetzt ein waschbecken mein
gott warum ist das denn darauf ist somit
das nächsten wir doch auch klar wir
machen das jetzt geschafft
plötzlich aus wie dein leben
ich glaube jeder mit gut schmeckt und
ich glaube die aus wird am besten
bekommen wo fangen wir an mit meinen
jetzt haben wir immer ausgemacht oder
will man mit dem rhein mitteilen wo ist
denn
wir müssen den einzigen
noch
extrem
sexy ihr könnt aber man hätte den
südring zwischen kirchners gar kein
alkohol drin
ich möchte ja nicht legal aber auch die
meisten zutaten schmeckt der strecke
oder meiner besten schmeckt mir zehn
punkte von 15 würde ich sagen wir sind
wald bilden drei vielleicht
nicht trinken ja mal richtig urlaub hey
leute nicht so wichtig aber kein
ganz kurz da drüben in zwei gläser nicht
ausgetrunken sie zu den jungen team
keine fünf wissen also von mir gibt
maximal eine 3 da kommen sollen hast du
ich gebe mir 5 ich habe ich fand meinen
so gut also
und noch 05 10 13 16
es gibt drei jahren aber nur was ist als
nächstes jetzt kommt er sich auch schon
ja sie hat so ein bisschen aus wie das
location
[Gelächter]
dollar hinaus gibt das sieht aus nach
zum ganz alten joghurt was in der
schwede live auf und ab erlebt dass ich
so ein bisschen raus wenn du diesen
diesen wackelpudding hast das schmeckt
wirklich dass ein kinder wackelpudding
[Musik]
ich finde ich finde die ähnlich schlecht
ab
denken kann ich hab dir 550 erheben
ach so dass mit absprache hier die
punkte geben eine vier watt sein für
mich was 3
da war schon ein bisschen mehr abenteuer
gibt auch eigentlich nicht geben
gebt mir ein angeblich 4,5 kirche mir
natürlich so täglich wir haben
absprachen
haben wir weil wir vielleicht wollte ich
demonstrieren wir haben keine abstriche
am gehalt machen wir da 90 wurden so
jetzt kommt meine dass jetzt mal das ist
jetzt alle sind sauer
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also ich finde ich in jeder und
trinkspruch costa maya
moment herrsche prompt ist herzig und
tomaten
ich hätte mir ein bisschen mehr limette
gewünschte
zuschauer
schmeckt arrabiata
[Gelächter]
das ist wie eine platte blinder einfach
ganz objektiv c erreicht tolle deko hat
komplett der name und jetzt auch klar
und übrigens lange warst also vom 14 55
uhr also social meinung nicht doch ich
ihn nicht dort war der marsch eines
betreuers in quitzow du bist immer nicht
rein ok 55 nein nein es gibt ja der war
schon gut der weg also ich gebe eine
zweieinhalb meter
durchmesser schneller im inland zu
scharfen tomatensaft schmeckt überhaupt
nicht gut und da ich plane die mary
liebe gibt es nicht mehr anders geplant
der aber das war mir zu schaden deswegen
jahr zweieinhalb punkte sonst neue
gewesen du kannst jetzt aber weil ja
komm ich typ 320 sowie
jetzt muss die mutter manager bereit
also die regierung wenig punkte nicht
dafür gäbe ja ja wir müssen jetzt
ruhig haben
es ist ein bisschen zu starker berlin
naja oder nur liest er aus schlechter
stunden flug mit ganz viel
haben
jetzt nach bismarck ist fast so banane
auf jeden fall hält sich im un ok wer
hier das war kommt auf meine forschung
ich gebe dem der war ungefähr auf das
niveau noch
nicht gefällt ganz kurz das ist immer so
die band verstößen gegen ihn seien aber
ich immer da hab ich überhaupt nicht ich
habe dir mehr punkte geben was du mir ja
gute entschuldigung aber die anderen
überhaupt nicht machen du machst und
ich gebe
wenn ich jetzt keine fünf kriege von ja
dann ist aber was du hast mir zwar
gegeben ich habe 3
302 so hatte ich nie viel gegeben gibt
es immer darum habe ich die nummer zwei
ist die breite ich ihm gesagt er hat
fünf gegeben drei also erkenntnissen auf
und das gibt dir selbst
[Applaus]
es ist so leicht fälschen anwalt wir
sind die besten konnte wechseln von
allen weil wir auch einmal drinnen vor
allen dingen richtig geschlafen haben
sie hat mixa mit vincent lindon manchmal
so oder so ich möchte mich so
schön wie kommst du
kannst du eine gute nacht aber noch mal
richtig auf eure neue single
freuen uns sehr dass du dir gefällt wie
gesunde
und spieler an nahrung wird gerne ihr
seid immer herzlich wieder eingeladen
mit dem braucht ihr müsst ihr übrigens
auch unseren song bewertung habe das im
hinterkopf sagt nein
sagen weil ich noch ein bitte nicht hier
kämpfen haben sind eine sehr viel besser
was ist das bergfest
aber richtig scheiße
ich hatte aber auch wo es schmerzt
natürlich ich habe das wäre mit kaffee
und menschen schmeckt gut schmeckt nach
aschenbecher aus
oder eine flasche wein paar kippen drin
hat
während sich jetzt selber ich werde mich
selber und während wir haben genau so
gut geschmeckt wie diner deswegen gebe
ich mir selbst auch punkte ich gebe dir
0,5
ich geb dir keine 5
also von mir gibt's 1
[Gelächter]
wenn ich mich hier nicht zweistellig
oder
dort gibt es einen ähnlichen
kommerziellen
110 10 111
dabei seine landen dann hat jetzt
gewonnen
[Musik]
adventskalender
den bus jetzt nämlich noch einmal an
alcon
wollt ihr noch ein letztes
abschließendes wort sagen vielen dank
dass ihr unseren song den ganzen tag
durchs leben und wir freuen uns auf die
nächste coup der stunde
[Musik]
[Applaus]